lines were joined by Jake Sherman he's a
senior writer for Politico and co-author
of politico's playbook newsletter Jake
good morning good morning I want to
start with Jeff Sessions and the latest
news excuse me that the Washington Post
is reporting about him I mean his status
at the beginning of the week when Donald
Trump was very critical of him was
seemed somewhat tenuous what do you
think how do you think this affects
things the problem is meeting with the
Russian ambassador is not even of itself
a bad thing testifying that he didn't
and when it comes out that he did is a
bad thing there's a lot of speculation
going on right now that this could be a
leak to help push him out because his
situation is obviously very very tenuous
the president's clearly not happy with
him he's not in the room anymore he used
to be a key advisor he's no longer a key
advisor so as you go forward what does
that mean for how he can deal with
Donald Trump it's very difficult to see
how he can on a personal level and how
he can on a professional level because
he the president values loyalty and Jeff
sessions in the president's eyes has not
been loyal to him on those lines it is
the AG's office that would be in charge
of the special investigation if it's not
sessions there then what does that mean
to the special investigation it means it
means that it's gonna there's no
supervision and also I think listen if
Donald Trump wants to push Jeff Sessions
out he's gonna have a huge fight on
Capitol Hill on his hands to get a new
attorney general something that he
cannot really afford at this point do
you think do you think the Senate would
resist him putting pushing him out I
think the Senate will have a lot of
questions we've seen in the last couple
weeks Senate Republicans increasingly
skeptical of Donald Trump willing to
question him these are all factors that
will be in play if he has to choose a
new attorney general you raised the you
raised the issue of loyalty yeah
Anthony scaramouch II talked to
yesterday was very open about saying I
love the president I'm loyal to the
president was that his chief
qualification do you think because he
doesn't have communications background I
can make a I can make two points here
that are in direct conflict with each
other number one he's going to be a good
press secretary for the president
because he's loyal he's willing to say
things that others aren't willing to say
I mean he went out and on his first day
and talked about the president hitting
foul shots and a topcoat in Madison
Square Garden but he has no
communications experience no government
experience the president has filled his
staff with people who have no experience
no applicable experience very good
experience in other in other quarters so
I think it's
I think it's scare Moochie is a huge
open question for me and you mentioned I
mean he's Director of Communications not
just press secretary so it has that
impact on everybody else as well and the
messaging is this another reset that
we're seeing by the Trump White House
the New York Times makes a good point
it's not a purposeful reset it's it's
definitely a reset but Sean Spicer was
expected to stay on the president
thought he would stay on so it's it's
definitely a reset but not something
that they had in mind
is it also a message to those who are
more of The Washingtonian types of
Reince Priebus as well Reince Priebus
his status is probably up in the air I
think that's fair to say and it is a
message to him that things are changing
any better get in line or you might be
in trouble but it seems that Priebus the
status has been up in the air for a
while I mean there have been reports
that you know people that the president
has been shopping around for a new chief
of staff I mean and then we know there
was resistance to scare emoji within the
White House so what essentially is this
saying you think I think that there's a
lot of palace intrigue without a lot of
backup right I mean there's been shake
up stories in newspapers from by people
like us for a long time and there hasn't
really been a shake-up I think it'll be
very difficult for the president to find
somebody to take rights per business
place because professional political
operatives look at this White House and
they see a president that does not
follow any guidance he does whatever he
wants so why would you go work for a
person who won't follow any of your
advice and I think that's something that
a lot of people that I talk to are very
cognizant of one of the things we're
going to see next week Jared Kushner
goes to Capitol Hill he'll be testifying
behind closed doors but you also have a
Donald Trump jr. and Paul Manafort who I
guess willingly given over some
documents what do we expect to see maybe
next week out of those two things I
would guess the president's gonna be
very agitated by this entire thing these
are people who are extraordinarily close
to him at least Kushner and his son and
I think this is gonna eat up a lot of
the week the president is facing has a
huge agenda he has not passed almost any
of it next week is the last week in
session for a congress that hasn't done
much this is gonna take up a lot of the
narrative a lot of that mind space of
the White House going into this August
recess
yeah healthcare on that back burner
there Jake Sherman thank you we
appreciate it thank you